hi and welcome to our session on Google
compute engine today we'll provide you
with an overview of the portfolio and
walk through the roadmap of what's
coming with Google compute engine my
name is Chris Ibaka mark I'm part of the
product management team in the Google
cloud organization let's start with
looking at the Google Cloud vision as
you are digitally transforming your
enterprises google cloud is providing
the organization's the best
infrastructure and platform capabilities
coupled with industry-leading solutions
portfolio to enable such a
transformation to happen as we look at
Google cloud the compute engine is at
its core within the compute engine that
is a variety of things that are
available from an overall portfolio
perspective for your infrastructure and
your infrastructure matters and the map
reason the infrastructure matters is all
of the right business decisions get
powered through your infrastructure and
the portfolio brett off the
infrastructure essentially enables a
wide variety of applications to become
available and the infrastructure
continues to be moving forward to
accommodate changes to your applications
and workloads we also want to make sure
that we're providing your teams the kind
of platform that they would need be it
the scientists or the data analysts or
engineers or developers Google cloud and
compute engine provide the broadest
variety of capabilities that cater to
the needs of all dining a little deeper
we're going to start with looking at the
performance and flexibility capabilities
of Google cloud for your enterprise
workloads to lead that I want to welcome
Aaron bless you
Thank You Krish a good at Google compute
engine we understand that enterprises
have a diverse and evolving set of
workloads and at different workloads
come with different priorities you may
have mission-critical databases where
every drop in performance counts or me
you may have back office applications
for which total cost of ownership is
King Google cloud provide to the
flexible range of capabilities to match
or demands your workloads may have and
we deliver them around the world we have
data centers on six continents and all
of our regions come with three
availability zones as standard
delivering the word your workloads to
your users and your customers wherever
they may be we provide the compute power
of Google compute engine through our VM
family portfolio we have the right
capabilities for your workloads across
the spectrum of offerings we have
compute optimized e - if general purpose
which is backed by both Intel and AMD we
have compute optimized for your HPC and
your scientific modeling applications we
can also go up to the high end for your
s AP Hana databases or your largest in
memory databases with our memory
optimized family and we are proud to
announce that coming soon we will be
adding a new VM family a - which has the
highest performance GPUs in the market
and of course your compute is only as
good as the storage behind it
we're expecting and we're expanding our
persistent disk offering to provide you
with the same flexibilities as our VM
families some workloads were optimized
for TCO where we will have an efficient
PD offering as well as going into
performance and extreme for your most
mission-critical applications and of
course local SSD continues to expand
with 9 terabyte offerings you can move
data around with Google's world-class
cloud network we offer a variety of
options for our customers include with
low latency large block sizes and ipv6
and as well as bring your own IP
important capabilities for any
enterprise of course if you for those
really really specialized we're closed
you now have a bare-metal solutions
bare-metal solutions is an intel cascade
Lake back offering with a variety of
sizes and storage options for your
special needs these are sent for
applications that may need to have
access to either the
special processor options that are not
offering flew through virtualization or
things that require bare metal for
licensing or locale and of course our ml
infrastructure where we are expanding to
a two or accelerator optimized family
with a 100 and video GPUs hundred gig
networking and of course our TPU
offerings what's new with TP use well
tube use we are going with TPU version 2
and version 3 pot pods are now available
in GA delivering up to 420 teraflops of
floating-point performance and include
custom high speed network that that
innate that allows TP use to work
together we are also expanding our
software ecosystem to help customers
build the highest performant supported
model libraries in the market today GPUs
are also generally available and backed
with gke and is a great way to can run
your containerized enterprise ml
workloads google cloud also continues to
expand its partnership with nvidia a 100
in videos ampere GPU is now available in
the a 2 vm family with optimized
accelerators for AI ml and HPC kad
started the ML training workloads years
ago and we are now expanding those
capabilities P 100 v1 under
top-of-the-line GPUs for high-end
training or joining our portfolio as
well as p4 and t4 an inference for hyper
scale we were the first cloud to launch
them and is only one to offer it
globally P 4 has the same tensor court
as the V 100 and is a great option for
scale out training if the V 100 compute
is beyond your needs now all of this is
delivering these innovative enterprise
solutions requires a full stack and
that's what I would like to turn it over
to Chris now to discuss thanks Aaron
Aaron just discussed the incredible
performance and flexibility that Google
cloud offers let's talk about things
that you could actually do on top of
that performance and flexibility that
Google Cloud
so let's take a look at some of the
enterprise solutions the first one we
will talk about is the Google VMware
engine GBE as we fondly call it is an
incarnation of your trusted VMware
portfolio including vSphere be Sam and
NSX combined into an asset service
offering that you could simply consume
off of Google Cloud there are a number
of innovative things that are happening
as part of GBE and if you look at that
roadmap starting from the Debu off GBE
shortly that is a significant amount of
expansion that is happening at Google
speed to new regions and then offerings
that are coupled with the GBE offering
that span the broad portfolio of GCP or
Google cloud available at launch is a
comprehensive set of B sector and nsx
manager capabilities right from day 0
more than any other cloud provider
seamlessly integrated with the GCP
experience a single place for billing
Identity and Access Management and VP
sea level protection let's take a
another solution ASAP on GCP or offering
a wide spread of sizes to meet a variety
of customer demands from the smallest
128 gig offering to the largest 24
terabyte plus offering for SME Hana
workloads and then providing more
choices including the AMD we call the in
2d platform there are 30% faster and
cheaper than previous offering
continuing to provide the certification
associated with s AP Hana is an integral
part of this overall offering let's take
a look at some additional enterprise
solutions that are there the next one
we're going to take a look at is Windows
as you can imagine the large variety of
workloads today continue to run on
Windows and GCP provides a first-class
Windows experience for all
our customers and this first-class
experience includes a managed Active
Directory capability it includes MS
sequel as part of cloud sequel and
support for Windows containers as part
of the gke offering all available today
coming soon
as part of our roadmap that is the
ability to migrate with anthos for
windows an automatically leap platform
your existing Windows Server 2008 r2
into Windows 2012 as part of the
migration itself and then there are
further enhancements both to gke and to
the Windows managed ad offering that we
are planning on looking at the next step
from an overall solution standpoint
there are times that you want to have a
level of isolation for your workloads in
the no share type of methodology Google
Cloud offers that level of control and
isolation and separation through its
sole tenancy offering these sole tenancy
offering allows you to run GCV VMs on
dedicated hardware and they are best for
cases where you have a compliance need
that is rooted on things like licensing
PCI compliance capex accounting and such
over the next two quarters as we
continue to evolve the sole tenancy
offering we aim to ensure that you would
have support for the entire VM portfolio
as we have it including local SSDs and
GPUs now as we look at all these
solutions a lot of this depends on the
migration of your workloads from the
existing on-premise barmen onto the GCE
environment to do that we have a variety
of steps that are curated that both GCE
and our
partners Google's partners can
collectively offer for you this includes
the discovery and assessment the
planning that's required for organizing
your on-prem workloads and bringing them
on to GCP the act of migration itself
and the post migration activities that
you'll need to do to ensure that the
migrated environment is fully optimized
from a cost performance and security
standpoint inside of GCP if you were to
double-click a little bit on to migrate
step we have a number of new
enhancements that are available
specifically as you're looking at
migrating your Windows 2008 r2
environment like we spoke before we
platforming allows you to turn that into
a server 2012 environment as part of the
migration itself cloud the cloud
migration both from AWS and Azure into
Google cloud has never been easier in
addition to that whether you're bringing
your own Linux or you're in the
container world or you're bringing
Windows containers we've made it very
easy for you to add them into Google
cloud looking at it a little further
beyond the performance and flexibility
that Google cloud offers and all of the
different enterprise solutions that you
can run on top of Google cloud we also
aim to provide an operational
environment that is the most conducive
in your cloud to do that we start with
live migration maintenance is an
integral part of running any
infrastructure but not in all cases test
maintenance need to be disruptive
actively managing your infrastructure
and application availability don't have
to be an either/or option at all
Google clouds innovative line migration
capabilities ensure that your workloads
are not impacted while the underlying
infrastructure goes through maintenance
a lot of times we have a need to
managed multiples of the MS together as
a group and that's really what managed
instance groups allows you to do this is
a way in which Google Cloud allows you
to take an instance and then create
multiple DMS from that instance and the
capability for Management doesn't stop
at just the creation of those multiple
instances but from an ongoing management
standpoint whether it comes to patching
whether it's come to auto scaling or
whether it comes to auto healing off
that environment managed instant groups
or makes allow you to take the burden
off of group management of multiples off
means continuing on the operational
excellence theme we're also proud to
present a number of recommendations that
are integral to your Google Cloud
experience these recommendations span a
broad variety of areas including cost
security efficiency just to name a few
the traditional approach to managing
your cloud environment is to throw more
money or staff at the problem in many
cases infinitely expanding your capacity
without fully knowing whether that is
being adequately utilized Google's
active assist recommendations allow you
to right-size your environment allow you
to learn more about idle resources and
providing you that automated proactive
intelligence that gives you the ability
to do more with less as an example
Google Cloud uses our intelligence to
automate the cooling of our own data
centers top of the mind for every
customer is the total amount of spend
that they have for their cloud
visibility control and optimized cost
are very important Google cloud offers
committed use discounts or cuts that
provide the best possible pricing
through deep discounts
against long-term commitments recently
we expanded our cuts to allow for multi
project coverage where you could go
ahead and apply cuts through multiple
parallel projects that you have as part
of your organization in addition to that
we have a number of new capabilities
that are coming up including Auto
renewing your cuts as they come up on
their one-year or three-year
anniversaries and also the ability to
schedule the start and stop off your VMs
in order to right-size them at any given
time to conserve the total use off the
number of course that you would have as
part of your commits it also does
suspend and resume VMs as part of this
overall offering patch management is a
incredibly hard problem to manage and
typically presents a significant burden
as part of infrastructure management
Google cloud lifts that burden away by
leveraging native OS tools and
automating the task of patch management
for you we have wide coverage of all
popular operating systems spanning from
Windows to several flavors of Linux
Google cloud also provides a number of
different controls that allow you to
target specific hosts as part of your
overall infrastructure within Google
Cloud it also provides the ability for
you to schedule your maintenance windows
and orchestrate your patch actions as
part of an overall patching capability
last but not least on the operational
end we're also providing OS config
management's capabilities that are today
at beta managing configuration in
configuration drifts is a hard problem
and we aim to make that easy with this
new beta an OS config management we're
presenting a compliance dashboard that
gives you details on config across Linux
dispersed in Windows and across hybrid
you can use third-party config tools if
you choose to to bootstrap packages and
deploy and maintain configurations
coupled with drift prevention very
easily with that in mind if we kind of
look at the stack a level higher and
look at security and data protection
they are integral parts of an overall
cloud portfolio to further the
discussion on that I'd like to turn it
over back to the Aaron thank you Chris
as you said security and data protection
are key to the cloud or to any cloud
offering as cloud adoption grows so too
does the challenge of keeping your cloud
workloads secure and protected security
and data protection are Google's top
priority and our infrastructure is
designed built and operated with
end-to-end security as a core design
principle from the physical premises to
the purpose-built servers networking
equipment security chips low-level
software stack running and every machine
our entire hardware infrastructure is
Google controlled secured built and
hardened now for many cases the security
is transparent to you as customer but
just by the virtue of operating on
Google DCP you are getting these
benefits today we'll be presenting a
number of exciting new features in that
area that we can extend as a result of
our end-to-end security practices
the first is confidential the end
customers can run any workload that they
usually run in a VM and by clicking a
simple checkbox that would transform
their VM into a confidential
now all the memory pages of the
confidential VM are are inline encrypted
the VM memory is encrypted by a key
perfume and generated in hardware this
is an AMD offering and we are very
excited to partner with them and bring
this to market and finally the customers
can protect their data end to end in
transit and at rest as well as in use
shielded VMs are also in GA and this is
something I thought it would be
important to highlight shielded VMs are
virtual machines on Google Cloud
Heartland by a set of security controls
that can help defend against rootkits
and boot kit attacks the set of
capabilities ensure that your VM
instances have a healthy and verified
operating system it also means that
protection from malicious systems
firmware and guest operating systems
tampering etc is hardly we hearted our
heart we are hardened it against those
attacks we do this through security
features up and down the stack including
UEFI firmware secure boot and virtual
trusted platform or TPM these integrity
measures make it so that you can trust
the operating systems that are running
in their clock additionally we have data
freak we are offering data protection
customer today customers have just one
size fits all option for data management
at a snapshot or goal for 2020 is to
make sure that copy data management that
fits for workload goals if you don't
want to do backups but you do want to
fork off your protect production disks
for testing staging etc then you can
clone we will clone the disks for you
and then cloning disarms I'm starting to
clone disk options are for you useful
for quickly turn investigating
production issues are performing backup
verifications without destructive
disturbing productions if you want to
enroll if you want to efficiently share
data with a partner then CBT is the
offering for you and if the word
expands the machines and it's GMI google
machine image which is coming out at
beta our call to action in this area is
to make sure and finally I'd like to
wrap up with our call to actions please
continue to to visit next twenty with
and look at our on-air updates from our
executives will also be diving deeper
into each of these areas storage TPU and
GPU accelerators security through other
sessions we invite you to discover why
the world's most innovative companies
are choosing Google cloud and we would
love for you to visit our YouTube
channel where you can work with builders
to explore api's data analytics machine
learning and the very best tools that
Google cloud has to offer once again I'd
like to thank my co-presenter Krish for
all for his help today and the team that
worked with us to put this presentation
together for you thank you very much for
your interest in Google cloud I hope to
see you out there soon